♪ ♪ ♪
- L'exposition de l'artiste
multidisciplinaire Stanl
Février au Musée national
des beaux-arts du Québec
humaine au 21e siècle.
Le titre de l',,,
en créole, est éloquent.
STANLEY FÉVRIER,
- C'est "menm vye tintin",
c'est "lêêême crisse
d'affaire", qu'on peut dire, en
québécois. Donc, plus ça change,
Donc, c'est pour ça que l'expo
s'lllllle comme ça. Je trouve
que c'est un contexte idéal
d'avoir un titre de cetteioioioe
très difficile humainement,
so
société. Mais quel changement
va être fait?
- Les oeuvres de l'artiste
abordent notamment les thèmes
discrimination et du racisme.
- Humainement, on est tous liés.
Ça paraît simple, mais
malheureusement, on oublie ça.
ça arrive qu'aux autres...
Mais l'autre, c'est aussi
une partie de nous.
- Les distorsions de l'image,
très présentes dans l'oeuvre
de Stanley Février,
évoquent différentes
formes de souffrance.
- Si on regarde cette oeuvre-là,
actuellement, combien de
personnes sont prises comme
Qui ne trouvent pas de mots,
comment parler, comment...
ou à qui on a carrément enlevé
le mot, la prise de parole,
ou qui se sentent eux-sssss
exclus socialement? Donc, c'est
ce que j'essaie de faire : créer
des espaces où ils peuvent
parler, crier. Pourquoi pas?
- Stanley Février esréréréréréat
du 4e prix MNBAQ en art actuel.
Plusieurs de ses oeuvres
intégreront les collections du
musée national, dont celle-ci,
qui rappelieieieieieie survenue
en 1927 à la Bath Consolidated
School, au Michigan.
ANNIE GAUTHIER, dir. collections
et expositio
- Ce qui me touche chez Stanley,
c'est un côté où il n'y a pas
de désillusion dans un message
aussi brutal, parfois. Il y a de
l'espot,t,t,t,t,t, chez Stanley,
malgré que ses oeuvres nous
ramènent à ce qui est le plus
sombre de la vie humaine
ou de l'être humain.
- Cette exposition percutante
et enrichissante sera présen
pendant près d'un an au MNBAQ.
Ici Valérie Cloutier,
Radio-Canada, Québec.